[Music]
thank you
hello America hey girl I'm Jimmy Fallon
the king of late night is off so instead
you get the Rodney King of late night
Good Start too soon it was 1992 you guys
yeah
thank you yeah I get beat up a lot on
the show for always mentioning that I'm
a former New York City cab driver but
the truth is I've had some pretty cool
experiences behind the wheel for
instance I once got to drive Al Pacino a
few blocks on the west side it was like
the weirdest thing ever because he got
in and I was like holy crap Al Pacino
and he was like holy crap a white cab
driver oh my God what are the odds
I've actually had tons of celebrities in
my taxi although I never drove Gutfeld
because we didn't have a kid seat
now if you're wondering I've also never
picked up Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
but unlike the cabbie who did I've
actually been in a high-speed chase
although it's worth noting that mine
happened on foot when I was a fat kid
chasing an ice cream truck but the point
is the point yeah growing up I felt bad
for being a guy who had a set of c-cup
boobies but looking back I actually wish
I had them now because I could get a Bud
Light endorsement you know Jimmy
Jimmy yeah you know we make fun of Dylan
Mulvaney but the truth is I'd rather
watch 10 hours of him pretending to be a
woman than sit through another second of
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
pretending to be a victim
thank you no two people have been handed
more and contributed lit yet less I'll
say that in English yet they shamelessly
continue to tell a country where 70 of
people are living paycheck to paycheck
that it's really hard to be royalty
please Harry and Megan are the type of
people who would visit a starving
Village in Africa and complain about how
full they were from the breakfast they
ate at the hotel
oh my gosh you guys I shouldn't have had
that last poach egg I'm so bloated
anyway
of course the only thing Harry and Megan
are starving for these days is attention
unfortunately for them there's a writer
strike in Hollywood so they were forced
to come up with their own story about a
high-speed chase that didn't pass the
sniff test with anyone in town not even
the poor stage manager Whoopi Goldberg
keeps farting on at The View
now to recap on Tuesday night Harry and
Megan attended a ritzy event at the
ziegfield theater where Megan received
the women of vision award you know for
that time she looked at the royal family
and had a vision of being the Yoko Ono
who broke it up
but as you can see from the photos Harry
rocked a pretty basic suit and like all
people who don't want the public looking
at the Megan wore a gold dress she also
had a tiny matching purse that she holds
Harry's balls in
[Applause]
it
now according to their publicist the
pair left the event at 9 50 p.m at which
point the waiting Paparazzi subjected
them to a quote Relentless Pursuit
lasting over two hours resulting in
multiple near collisions involving other
drivers on the road pedestrians and two
NYPD officers folks this supposedly
happened in New York City take it from a
former cab driver New York City traffic
move slower than a conversation between
these two
really think about this for a second New
York is the only city in the world where
bank robbers flee on foot
[Laughter]
you've never turned on the news and seen
a high-speed Bank get away because it
could never happen guy would come
running out of the bank like dude I got
the money where are you this buddy be
like dude I couldn't get a spot I'm so
sorry
now a member of their security detail
told CNN that at multiple points
Paparazzi were jumping curbs and blowing
red lights saying I have never seen or
experienced anything like this now I do
believe him when he says he's never seen
anything like it because according to
the NYPD it didn't happen a police
source told the New York Post at no time
was there a high-speed chase there were
no Collision reports or 9-1-1 calls and
the chase definitely was in two hours
meaning Prince Harry's story about a
high-speed car chase has more holes than
Prince Andrew's orgies on Epstein Island
Jimmy
hey seriously lay off prince Andrew the
guy's stressed out right now it's
already Megan he doesn't even have a
prom date lined up yet
we didn't need the cops to tell us this
story was fake because the lack of video
evidence told us everything we needed to
know New York is the most videotaped
city on earth if a rat takes a bite of
Pizza on the subway it goes viral in 30
minutes and he's known throughout the
world as Pizza rat folks
you can't even pleasure yourself in your
apartment without getting caught on
video in this town
[Applause]
but seriously if two British Royals were
in a high-speed chase out of the French
Connection there would be a zillion
videos all over the internet but once
again the only thing Harry and Megan
were fleeing was the truth the cab
driver who picked them up after they
stopped off at the 19th Precinct told
the Washington Post quote I never felt
like I was in danger it wasn't like a
car chase in a movie he went on to say
that the trip only lasted 10 minutes
before he took them back to the police
station at which point they made it home
on their own yeah it turns out Harry and
Megan should have visited San Francisco
because like the sidewalks they're both
full
okay
but they'll continue telling woe is me
stories because they worship at the
altar of celebrity victimhood they make
all their money convincing broke
commoners to feel bad for Rich Royals
and it's a great con but at this point
we all know the truth Harry and Megan
don't want to be left alone because if
they really wanted privacy they'd get a
prime time show on CNN
period
let's welcome tonight's guests he's so
Nashville his blood type is Mesquite
founder of outkick the co-host of the
clay Henry and buck buck Sexton show
clay Travis
as an NFL reporter she saw Brett Favre
naked without getting a text from him
host of the Michelle Tafoya podcast
Michelle Tafoya
he looks like the stepdad in a low
budget porn TV producer and writer Rob
long in the house there it is
she takes no prisoners because she can't
carry them Fox News contributor and New
York Times best-selling author Kat 10th
and a half
hey girl hi I'll go to you first wasn't
the lack of video evidence to tell here
exactly for two hours nobody was filming
it because yet nobody here wants to be
famous or go viral most people don't
live in New York City like even
accidentally like a tick tocker filming
a dance on the sidewalk would have
gotten this pandemonium in the
background I mean it's crazy oh they're
so funny and I just also don't
understand what they meant by like near
catastrophic near collisions yeah do you
mean like people cutting you off
because like that's Tuesday yeah in New
York City everything you do here is near
fatal you know what I mean but the most
remarkable thing is that they think we
are so stupid yes like the fact it's so
obvious anyone who's ever even like seen
a movie about New York realizes that
this isn't possible and they're like
we're gonna get through this and
everyone's gonna they don't just want
attention they want people to feel so
bad for them yes it's a victim correct
it's a victim grift which gets really
old when you're literal royalty and then
said no thank you like my problems have
been different like I was the princess
and I didn't want to be
think about that parents pay a thousand
dollars an hour at Disney they have to
pretend to be a princess yeah and she's
like this gig sucks I can't believe it
uh but clay let me go to you because you
were sticking off for Megan in The Green
Room you say she's misunderstood oh yeah
I've always been a big Meghan Markle
person uh actually I couldn't hear
anything in the green room because you
brought in 1990s rap did I ever did I
ever that's not even a joke it was
awesome uh he walked in with his own
soundtrack and it was all 90s rap uh but
look to me cat kind of building on this
first of all why wouldn't you just pose
for the photos with the paparazzi take
the photo right I mean no one's ever
tried to take my photo ever right but if
you're so concerned there's like six
Paparazzi come out you're dressed really
nice I understand if you've got kids
with you or if you're not expecting to
get your photo taken at six a.m maybe
you're a little bit antagonistic with
them take the photo and then just get in
a normal car and go to your place I
don't want to sit in traffic for two
hours to go anywhere if you told me
right now hey when the show's over
you've got to get in a two-hour car ride
I would be like no I I I'll walk
wherever you need me to go so all of
this I find them I find Meghan Markle to
be the most detestable person in media
right now and she really is in media
right with all the shows that they do
and I would just say this
if you ever get married or date someone
and they demand that you renounce your
entire family as a precondition for that
relationship in some way run in the
opposite direction she's awful and she's
trying to destroy Harry I feel bad for
him well you know I I'm with you there
the only place we differ is I do get
photographed a lot no people come up to
me they're like oh my God you're that
before-up model from the diet ad oh my
God
you're the other guy on the left side of
the screen in the Slim Fast Dad I know
you
um is Meghan Markle a worse actress or a
worse screenwriter based on the story
from Tuesday night well I gotta say like
I am a member of the writer's Guild I am
on strike go writers I'm 100 in in favor
of the writer's Guild I'm picking and
doing all that thing I think writers
have a good point I would although I
would be a scab just to punch up that
story
[Laughter]
probably have offered that just pro bono
I'll probably get kicked out but I'll do
it anyway none of it made sense but
here's the thing about Harry Megan that
people forget
yeah
I am so bored
with these two
I'm so bored with their story I'm bored
with like what happens now on board with
the kids I was born with the coronation
I didn't care I am so bored with this
that I really kind of feel like um they
owe us a bet either either go away and
they come back and have you know get
really fat and come back 20 years from
now or um or do something a lot more
interesting than that yes like like
solve a crime you know what I mean like
like do do it make a difference yeah
make a difference in some way just be on
a show yeah but but not that that was
just sort of lame and sad and boring and
uh needs a punch-up thank you no and I
agree I think you know who else is bored
with them though I think they are
Michelle I think they're bored because
this is what I think happened okay she
married into the royal family because
she wanted relevance she was a USA Today
actress she saw major relevance in the
form of Harry but she didn't understand
that when it comes to succession his
only chance of wearing the crown was
having a birthday party at Burger King
you know what I mean so only one day a
year would he get to wear it so do you
think she's bored and she's trying to
make this life interesting because it's
just a waste now he is a spare as his
book says he is a spare I will say this
I think he might be behind this more
than she is because remember that he is
suing for further protection while he's
in England he needs more security and I
think there is a lawsuit underway for
him to get this additional security well
what better way to get in to say when I
was in New York and this was official
business or whatever it was I was you
know under this great duress but here's
the other thing she was getting an award
for a woman of vision and I think the
reason she was getting this award for
being a woman of vision is because she
has her very own truth it doesn't have
the truth she has her truth and that is
her vision and her vision that night
must have been quite something I wish I
was living in her head because there is
no way in hell look we weren't there I
want to be nice but I can't be because
there's no way in hell this happened
he's in New York and nobody sees it
there's just no way no so I think this
is a play for extra security money for
Harry you know who uh the big winners
here the writers of her old show Suits
that guarantee you they went through
after some table readings she was like
really would this ever really happen
like will you try it yourself lady she
tried it and you know it turns out you
need writers
Megan might have settled the strike
that's funny yeah right you need writers
you need people thinking hard about
whether this like is this really
exciting or not needs a second act he's
a third act twist it can't it can't be
two hours driving around the cab I think
it's hilarious and I agree with you on
the women of vision because I've watched
her interviews Stevie Wonder has better
Vision okay that's a mess that he does
he's not watching folks it's okay
be listening God love you Stevie he's a
national Treasurer before we go come see
me on tour I will be in Clearwater
Florida this Saturday the 20th of May
Davenport Iowa on June 3rd Mesa Arizona
June 10th and Lexington Kentucky on June
24th hey girl hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else